- The whole shape surprised me.
- There are many curves in that building
and there are also two emblematic cuts.
- I will tell you what the
construction authorities
said about the house.
They said, it's the "Tear"
or "The Eye of the God."
I mainly see a teardrop.
The Eye of the God is the sun
who comes all over the place.
Hello! My name is George
and welcome to our home.
(Bright, cheerful music)
I live in Heraklion.
We decided to buy this
ground because of the view.
So, we are entering the main living room.
This room is the room of light.
You have a lot of sunlight.
In Crete, we are people
who live with the light.
Light is all over. It's very aggressive.
The curve in front of the house
is uh, philosophically the
resistance of the concrete to the sun.
- (Tilemachos) It seems
the house necessarily
would face this radiant sun.
It should be more
receptive, it should be bent
by the sun's course from East to West.
- You will go to the kitchen
where, if you have a good cook,
you can prepare something fantastic to eat
because Crete has a lovely
variety of very good food.
- (Tilemachos) The
living room is in between
the cantilevered volume
and the volume of the base,
which acts as a podium and
hosts the sleeping quarters.
- (George) Most of what
is going on in the house,
you cannot imagine that from the outside.
Going up the staircase,
one enters the guest room
that is in contact with
two open air spaces.
The one is evident on the
facade, it is its main cut.
The other one is completely
hidden from public view.
It is a cut of the roof underneath which
one may find an open air bath.
- I wouldn't advise you to jump in it,
but it's very nice
to cool your body in the very hot nights
or days of the summer.
And we have a lot of them.
The other part is also very interesting,
because at that part,
you have the Tear of God.
And that's the view.
That's the head of Zeus
who's very kindly to us in Crete.
So now for the easy part,
I will take the elevator
to show you the rest of the house.
Hello again.
So here we are entering our main bedroom.
This is the master bedroom where we sleep.
We have two more for the kids.
So I'll show you my
secret place in the house.
And my secret place is very
easy to access because you can
open the trap and you just
have to go downstairs.
It's meant to be a place where
it's quiet and I can rest.
Fortunately enough,
sometimes I can do that.
(Upbeat music)
Let me show you, last but
not least, one other thing
that is one of my demands
that I had for this house.
So this is my playground for adults.
It's meant to put a car on
it and to turn it around
so you don't need to maneuver here.
(Cheerful music)
- (Tilemachos) This is one
of the most peculiar designs
that we have tried.
And I had certain doubts about,
not the architecture itself,
I was more concerned about
its relation to the city.
But then I said, okay, we have to try.
I think that they
essentially work together.
They get more alive in my
eyes because of each other.
That neighborhood was invigorated
by this playful house.
And this playful house is in a
sculptural dialogue with its neighbors.
(Background music fades)